et nous sommes maintenant communication
avec un auditeur au bénin qui à 23 ans
il est étudiant en géographie
il s'agit de hamidou 5 à la fia hamidou
bonsoir quelle température fait s'il
présentement au bénin une moitié à
cotonou c'est la matrix qui est riche et
al l'harmattan et est un vent oui elle
va fait qu'ils viennent d'une heure du
nord très bien nous sommes en période à
moteur et il fait environ une 3d gray 22
et 23 voilà c'est frais c'est très frais
il n'y a pas trop de soleil avec un peu
de ses cris fier là dessus le ciel un
peu couvert
on pourrait dire que c'est un petit peu
la saison sèche chez vous et moi c'est
la saison fait à cotonou nous sommes on
suit donc pas quitter le nord ils
peuvent voir qui fait le nord où vivait
le sud ça se déplace vers le sud en ce
moment oui vous avez une question qui
porte sur le froid au canada sion
l'hiver c'est quoi exactement
en fait je voulais savoir comment est ce
que les canadiens arrivent à se protéger
du froid fait que canada le pôle nord il
est là bas il fait effectivement fois
donc je ne voudrais savoir comment est
ce que les canadiens arrivent à se
protéger du froid comme insulte à
arriver à faire face au froid qui
provoque au canada il ya quelque chose
qui se produit qui se produit pas chez
vous c'est des gens qui décèdent en
raison du froid chaque année y en a pas
chez vous ce sera un possible effet oui
on meurt de froid et ses 80 personnes
qui meurent de froid chaque année au
canada
c'est quand même assez important il ya
les sans abri qui sont vulnérables il ya
les aînés les personnes plus âgées et
aller bébé et et c'est très sérieux
et il ya les nouveaux arrivants au
canada qui sont way qui sont pas
adaptées aux risques d'engelures et
d'hypothermie ils là c'est pas quelque
chose que j'invente il nouveaux
arrivants sont une des populations
vulnérables au froid les enfants les
bébés
et puis les étrangers qui ne sont pas
deux fois
oui c'est eux qui sont les plus
vulnérables il ya ou faux produit aussi
les sans abri alors comment se protéger
du froid
il faut s'habiller chaudement faut
manger beaucoup de absorber beaucoup de
calories et la hamidou je vous donne un
exemple si vous travaillez
par exemple en antarctique un sas est
complètement à l'autre côté de la
planète mais ça ressemble beaucoup à la
situation au pôle nord il ya des
travailleurs là bas qu'ils sont en train
de mettre sur pied un nouveau
laboratoire américain
un centre de recherche américain de
conception très spécial sur pilotis on
s'est aperçu que les ceux qui
construisent les bâtiments ont besoin au
minimum de 6000 calories par jour
simplement pour pouvoir rencontrer la
dépense énergétique qu'ils le doivent
louer que leurs corps doivent dégager
l'un pour se prémunir contre le froid
est en général une personne a besoin de
2000 à 2004 100 calories par jour en
temps ordinaire menace et 6000 calories
qu'il faut il faut manger du foie de
l'âme c'est presque trois fois c'est ça
la tradition au canada pour bien
s'habiller c'est la fourrure de castor
la fourrure de castard ça se fait plus
beaucoup aujourd'hui la laf hourdebaigt
on piège le castor qui se promènent le
long des ruisseaux qui se trouvent dans
les rivières
c'est un animal d'assez bonne taille là
je pense que il a une grosse que aplatit
et il a un poil très très rugueuse un
castor canadien sa mesure entre un
maître et 1,2 mètre de long c'est quand
même trop
c'est pas petit il a une grosse que
c'est un rongeur et c'est le deuxième
des plus grand rongeur du monde après un
rongeur qui s'appelle le capybara qui
lui en amérique du sud et lorsque le
canada est devenu le canada lorsque les
colons d'europe sont arrivés chez nous à
l'époque coloniale donc il ya eu ce
commerce de peaux de castor
non seulement les colons ici l'utilisait
pour se tenir au chaud mais on en voyait
ça en europe
c'était tellement populaire en europe
les gens aimaient tellement se protéger
du froid avec les podcasteurs du canada
ou des états-unis que cet animal était
pourchassé jusqu'à la limite de
l'extinction
ouais nan maintenant comment les
canadiens se protègent aujourd'hui du
froid il faut bien s'habiller tout
simplement en multipliant les couches de
linge en ce moment là j'ai des sous
vêtements
je donnais raconter toute ma vie là mais
j'ai des sous-vêtements en bas et en
haut
oui juste pour vous faire comprendre gd
des caleçons pour se protéger du froid
j'ai cent en dessous de mes pantalons et
je ne me sens absolument pas la morsure
du froid lorsque je suis doublé comme ça
j'essaie double protection et pour ce
qui du haut est bien là je porte
toujours deux t-shirts 1 à manches
courtes et manches longues et pardessus
sein comme aujourd'hui j'ai ajouté un
long chandail manches longues et lorsque
j'aurai terminé de parler avec toi que
gérer je prendrai le train de banlieue
pour retourner chez moi j'aurais ajouté
bien sûr mon manteau d'hiver où le
rembourrage effet de duvet qui fait en
sorte que l'air l'air froid mais
beaucoup de temps à traverser
lorsqu'il vient de l'extérieur il m'a
beaucoup de temps à traverser vers vers
ma peau voilà j'espère que ça répond un
petit peu à la question que tu nous
avais posé sur le froid merci beaucoup
puis ne te gêne pas pour nous poser
d'autres questions
si jamais le goût tu viens d'accord
merci beaucoup hamidou et puis à la
prochaine sacca lafia hamidou qui se
trouve au bénin